in Hong Kong today an anti-government
protester was shot at point-blank range
by a police officer and it's caught on
tape another man was set on fire both
incidents come on the worst weekday
violence in more than five months of
demonstrations there Ramey Inocencio is
monitoring the developments from Beijing
and we should warn you the video of the
shooting is quite graphic this skirmish
quickly takes a violent turn a police
officer attempting to subdue one
protester dressed in white is confronted
by another dressed in black three shots
are fired and the 21 year old falls to
the ground shot in the abdomen at
point-blank range police later said the
man was trying to seize his weapon and
did not want to hurt him several hours
later a man his face already covered in
blood was caught on tape arguing with
someone off camera he's doused in fuel
and set on fire which was later
extinguished on Monday protesters
brought the workday to a halt
smashing Chinese owned banks and
businesses throughout the central
business district police responded using
tear gas and water cannon to subdue the
protesters while office workers fled
violence that is now routine Hong Kong
chief executive Carrie Lam violence is
not going to give us any solution to the
problems that hong kong is facing our
joint priority now
as a city is to end the violence and to
return hong kong so normal as soon as
possible
now these protests are actually a
spillover from the weekend that's when
one young student protester died after
falling from a car park and dying from
his injuries as for the two men we saw
today both of them are still in critical
condition
Tony Randy thank you very much